anyone who wants to know what does it
take to create change in short periods
of time you got to look around and you
got to say there's only a few people
that be able to consistently do that
produce those results and Erickson's one
of them
he was profoundly aware of the shifts of
consciousness of people here it was
almost like magic the stories about his
perceptiveness are legendary person they
have nine traits is not an accountant
and he can do what he chooses better
than he can with no way to state with a
lightning flash of the risks he threw
the stone directly at me and he said why
would you want to see yourself sitting
over there in that chair that's all he
needed to do he didn't believe he was
psychic but he seems like sometimes I
was five when he had infantile paralysis
they tell his mother the boys gonna die
tonight sometimes I'd feel gosh I wish
he would just be ordinary and say I have
a nice day they did not understand we
call his genius today because he was so
different the security became amplified
compared to which most of us are deaf
dumb blind a lot of people call him the
crazy man out of Phoenix
he helped J Edgar Hoover we got a letter
from him he went further than what I
would choose today I was really
for the first time in my life he looked
at me and he said the way you see it is
not the way this